Okay.
In this video we'll see a more general
algorithm for performing in France in
general conditional random fields
known as belief propagation.
Okay.
So we've seen in the previous
video that we could, uh,
visually illustrate a,
uh,
undirected graphical model like a
conditional random fields that we can be
written as a product of factors into a
factor graph where we have a graph it
notes that correspond to random variables
and other notes that correspond to the
different factors in the model.
Okay.
One advantage of the fact of graph is
that it provides a good representation for
a actually deriving and illustrating the
types of computations that we must do
to perform inference in a,
uh,
undirected graphical model of like a
conditional random fields. Uh, in fact,
the forward backward algorithm that
we've seen before for a computing,
the alpha bed,
a tables which are useful for unnecessary
to compute the marginals in a linear
chain conditional random fields can be
rented in the more general form where, uh,
in, uh, it's a specific case,
it boils down to the forward backward
algorithm. But for a general,
a conditional random fields,
it provides now an algorithm for these
more general cases or performing imprints.
Okay.
Specifically belief products or this
algorithm is known as belief propagation.
It's a message fashioning algorithm
in the sense that now in the graph,
each node,
the notes are going to exchange
messages between them and uh,
the messages are going to be
exchanged normally until convergence.
That is until the messages that one though
the sending to another node does not
change. And, uh,
the idea is that the messages that one
node is going to send to another note is
going to be a combination of,
uh,
things that come from the
factors associated with
that node and messages that
were received from its neighbors.
Okay.
So there are actually going
to be two types of messages.
Much like there are two types of nodes
in the factor of graft are going to be
two types of messages.
Um,
so there are going to be messages from a
variable nodes which are illustrated as
a circle in the graph, uh,
to its neighbor factor notes,
which are the squares,
uh,
the messages they're going to
be defining a recursive form.
So the message from a variable node,
which is a illustrated,
uh, it's not an s to a,
a node that is a factor.
So we use f two of a
straight factor notes.
So the message from s two f
when the node as takes value,
I is just going to be the product of the
messages that all the other factors f
prime which are connected to s and
are not f so the note f one that send
messages recursively to itself.
So it's,
it's going to receive the messages that
other factors of prime I've sent to s
four, again, the uh, uh,
where we assumed that the
node s is taking value. I,
so we take all the messages that have
been sent to s and we multiply them
together and that becomes the
message that s is going to send to f.
And what we take the
product of fat of messages,
we only take the messages
from factors f Primes,
which are not f but our
neighbors are connected to us.
Okay.
So in this illustration here,
the message from s two F is going to be
the product of the messages that come
from this. And this note, this factor
node here in this factor are not here.
So this would be one of the F primes
and this would be another APP.
And now the messages from a factor
node to a neighbor variable node,
it's going to be slightly
more complicated. Um,
so the message from f two s where,
uh,
s stakes is assumed to take
value. I, so for instance, in, uh,
if s is a label note than I would
be a potential label for that, uh,
for that label node is going to be
now not just a product but as some.
So we're going to have a sum over the
value of all the other variables that,
uh, are involved in the factor, the
factor that's sending a message.
Uh, but we're in this,
some will keep the, uh,
value of the node s two,
which we're sending message to its
value where assuming, which is I,
which is this here.
So we take the value of the
factor for all vectors zed where,
uh, all the values of all
the other variables, uh,
involved in this factor are being
changed to their potential value.
We trade of all of these values except
for the note as which we keep fixed to
eye.
And when you take that value,
we would also multiply the messages
that all of the other neighbor nodes.
And so the neighbor nodes here are going
to be variable notes as primes that are
neighbors of f except the note
to which we're sending a message.
S So we're going to multiply all,
all the messages that these, uh,
notes s primes Av sent to f and uh,
we're a US also take into
account in this some,
what is the value that that, uh, uh,
note as frying is taking in the
variables involved in the factor.
So visually,
uh,
the message sent from this factor to that
variable node is going to involve the
messages that came from all other
variable notes that are not s and a,
it's going to be the product of
these messages. But then, um,
there are going to,
uh,
we're going to get the message for
each potential value that each of these
variable node can take.
And you're going to be combined
together and waited by the, uh,
factor associated. They're sort of
factor that is sending the message.
And then we're going to some over
all potential values that these,
this variable known in this
variable note could take.
So to make this more concrete,
we're going to do the, uh,
specify a specific case
of a linear chain CRF,
and it's going to be simplified so
we won't have a context window. Uh,
we'll just have why one be connected to
x one and y two, I'll need two x two.
So here we have our equations for
the messages and now, uh, we'll uh,
do a few iterations of the
messages, uh, where we compute a,
a few of them in, uh,
actually will, we'll, uh,
in this example only do from
left to right for now. So, uh,
first we, uh, initially, uh, we
initialize all the messages to one.
So the mew messages all going
to be set to one initiative.
That's usually the
starting condition we use.
Now let's consider the message that
is stent from x one to this factor.
So a message from a
variable nodes to a factor,
a node, it should be the product
of all the messages that the, uh,
variable no that's received
from other factors except f.
Now in this case,
x is only involved in one factor.
So there are no other messages when this
case will the product of nothing. Uh,
we'll set it to one by definition.
Next,
we'll consider this
message here from this,
this factor through that variable node.
So if we look at the formula here
from the factor to a variable note,
uh, what we have to do is that
we have to some, so, okay,
so this factor,
uh,
involves y one and x one.
And then while what do we have to do is
to some over all values involved in the
factor that is x one and y one,
except that we keep the value of the
note to which we're sending the message.
So that's s two,
it's specified value in the message.
So that's I hear and also we only some
over the variables that are on observed.
Uh, so in this case x one is given.
So we keep it fixed also too.
It's a given value. So in
fact, in this case, we, uh,
have only one term in the song and
that's the term where a x one takes the
specified value and why one takes a also,
it's uh,
the value.
Hi.
So removing the ink,
uh,
the message being sent to why one from
this factor is going to be the value of
the factor four x one. And, uh,
some given while you value
of y one being cool to I,
so that's this term times the message
that was received by this factor from
other value variable nodes. Stan, why one?
So the only other message is
this message here, which is one,
so one times that cause this will be the
expression of the message and all this
that when I say that I see for a
given value I, for the variable node,
it means that I need to send what
this message is for all values.
I have the variable node in
question. Uh, so in this case,
when I'm sending a message to a y one,
um,
it can take as many values as the
number of classes from one to see.
So we'll need to compute this
expression for eye being one, two,
three up to capital's seat. And
so when I'm sending, uh, this,
uh, I'm, can,
I can think of it as sending a vector
actually where each element of the vector
is a different value of the message
for different values of, of I.
And so I could just take the exponential
of the lug you neri factor for all
value possible values for [inaudible]
and send that as the message of,
uh, this factor to the
variable node. Why one.
Okay,
then we have to send message
from y one, two, this factor.
So we have a message from a
variable no to a factor node,
assuming that our variable
takes, uh, some given value. I,
and that needs to be the product of all
messages that were sent to the factor,
um, to the factor. Sorry to
the variable note f except,
uh, s sorry. Except f.
So in this case, uh,
the,
uh,
other message I could have come in from
other factors would be this message.
So we'll have the product of just this.
It's the only other factor message that
this is receiving except from a message
from this guy, this factor
node. So the message sent by,
uh, I, uh,
why one to this factor would just
be the exponential of the union.
Every factor for the value of y one,
which would be I,
so we'd have the vector of exponential
of [inaudible] exponentially. Like,
hey you two and so on,
this vector would be sent to that fact
factor.
Next we have the message from this
factor no to that variable note.
So that's this rule here.
Now we have to some over all,
uh, the values of the random
variables involved in the factor f.
So it's this factor.
So the variables are y one and y two
but have to keep zed s to its value.
I,
so in other words,
we have to send the messages for each
value of I where we do the sum and we take
the variable to which we are sending
a message and we keeping it to that
specified value.
I and otherwise for the other
variables we some over their values.
So in this case we're sending to y two.
So where are you going to
some over the value of y one.
So we have to some over
why one of this factor,
the factor here,
which is the pairwise factors.
So it's the exponential of
the pairwise factor here.
Times all the messages that comes from
other variable nodes as prime that are
not s and that'll work send to f.
So essentially this message here,
so that message here,
so have the exponential of a u y one
times the exponential of a p y one y two.
So that's equivalent to the exponential
of Aui one and AP. Why One? Why too.
And then we're summing over the
other variables that are not y too.
So that's in this case.
Why One?
Okay.
And uh,
so that's this message that's being sent
from that factor to this variable Nov.
Let's, so mink, oh,
and notice that this is actually the
initial value of the first column in the,
uh, uh, computation of the Alpha table
in the forward backward algorithm.
So we see we're starting to recover pieces
from the forward backward algorithm.
Okay,
next we could send the
message from here to there.
So with a similar reasoning as
in this case here, we get one
and would a similar reasoning.
The message from this factor
to this variable node would
just be the exponential
of the urinary factor, uh, for the, uh,
position two in the sequence.
Okay.
Now the message sends from Y to, to
this factor despair, wires factor.
Uh,
so we are in this rule here.
S F would be the product of all
the messages from other factors,
F primes that are not f and
that are connected to s.
So it's the product of that
message and that message,
which is this expression here or
equivalently alpha on, why two,
we lose our notation from
the Ford backward dollar with
them, which we find here.
It's the product of this times that,
okay.
And now if we compute the
message to white three,
then uh, again, where we get is the, uh,
some over the other variable
that shares the same factors.
So that's why two of the pairwise factor
here times all the messages that were
sent to,
uh,
all the messages that were sent
to f from variable known as prime,
which is connected to f n
which is not [inaudible].
So in this case it would be,
uh,
it would be that message here.
So we see that we have some overweight
to the other and a variable nodes of the
exponential of a,
a two why to just here
times Alpha One y two,
which is here and times
the exponential of,
uh, deep pairwise factor,
which we can just put it into
the same exponential here.
And so this corresponds to the
pairwise factor in this expression here
corresponds to this factor.
So if you continue like this,
in this sequence, in this order of the
messages, we actually recover all of the,
uh,
of equations for the values of the Alpha.
So the column in the
Alpha tables. And so, uh,
so this is just,
you know,
at the beginning of the demonstration
that there are equivalent and you know,
a full demonstration, we
actually show you that, uh, uh,
and so would the validate
that a belief propagation, uh,
applied from left to right and then
right to left actually yields the
computation of all the Alpha table and
then the computation of the better table.
So, yeah, so actually if you look at this,
we actually do a recovered the expression
for the second column of the Alpha
Table. And so by proceeding like
this, we recovered all of the,
uh,
of table columns.
So yeah. And for the, to
sum up for the linear chain,
a linear chain graph,
belief propagation is actually the
same as the forward backward algorithm.
The Ford Pass computes the Alpha table,
the backward pass the bed a table,
uh, for the similar reason for an the
miracles stability, we actually, uh,
usually implement a version
that passes log messages.
So that's going to be
more stable numerically.
And one advantage of the message
passing out with them is that, uh,
the belief propagation algorithm is that
we can do in France now on other types
of structure. Now, interestingly,
belief propagation yields Zack inference
if are a structure of our factor graph
is a tree and arbitrary retreat
actually. So, uh, if we,
uh,
so we can show that belief propagation
actually eventually converges by
computing the, uh, uh, if we compute
the, uh, each of the messages,
eventually the messages
stop changing. And, uh,
and the actually correspond to what
you would like the messages to be.
So if you locked space,
uh,
the log some of the factors
for all of the variables,
uh, that's, uh, come from
a given part of the tree.
And so these long messages can be
used then to provide a do approximate
inference. And in particular
compute marginals, the, uh,
general algorithm with the same equations
can all be so be applied to a graph
which has loops.
Uh,
so in this case it would not
correspond to a tree and, uh,
and then it's often use it practice to
do approximate inference. So, uh, uh,
obtained some approximate estimates
of what the marginals could be.
Uh, you have to be careful. I'll
ever, the algorithm could divert. Uh,
so there are certain tricks that,
uh, are used to make it converge.
Uh, so I ref, you know, there's,
there's a vast body of literature on
a message passing algorithms and loopy
belief propagation,
which I won't cover. Um,
but so one trick that is
tough time sometimes uses
that instead of updating the
messages by overriding them,
you instead,
when you recompute a message,
a second password,
you competing the same
message a second time,
you actually do some sort of weight of
average between the current message and
the previous message. Cause that's
one trick that's sews for, uh,
having a better behaved a algorithm.
So I'm not going to the detail in part
because there are actually a lot of
general purpose libraries that are
publicly available where we just pass the
graph in a certain and data structure
and then the algorithm will do this,
uh, uh, message fascinating until belief
propagation. We'll run it over your graph,
uh,
and uh,
and these areas quite useful because then
they can be used on arbitrary types of
graphs.
So it means that now instead
of constraining ourselves
to a linear chain CRF,
before doing a sequential classification,
we could start considering
adding a lateral connections
between labels that are
at two positions away from each other.
So I have factors between
whyK and why k plus two.
Uh, so even if this would
introduce some loops in the, uh,
in the model, we could
still deal with those. Uh,
we could add also lateral connections,
uh,
for triplets of labels as well.
Um,
so really we can just explore a bunch
of different types of graphs by, uh, uh,
adding factors as we wish.
And then from these factors,
we get a factor of graph and from
the fact that graph, this would, uh,
describe the way of passing messages
between a variable nodes and fat log fire
and factors and from factors.
So variable notes.
So the idea really is when we do
CRF modeling is that you want to add
connections between the things that have
dependencies are fairly strong and that
you want to model directly.
And in fact,
you can have a connectivity that
varies between examples. Uh,
so if you have some information,
uh, that differs between examples,
which would tell you that for one example,
for instance,
the first label should really be
connected to the last label, for instance.
But for other, uh, maybe four other,
uh, structures, you don't want this,
you could actually have a separate,
essentially graph,
separate factor ref for each training
example when you're actually, uh, uh,
and you could actually
train such a CRF as well.
So examples of,
uh,
graphs that we often see
for a computer vision.
We could have a grid structure.
So imagine we were labeling each
pixel in the image by, uh, uh,
maybe a segmentation, uh,
label, which tells us, uh,
which may be separates a
foreground from background. Well,
then we flew on to, uh, the
labeling to be fairly smooth.
We could have factors
between each pair of, uh, uh,
pixels like this.
Uh,
Dell are adjacent in the grid of pixels
so that the labeling is a somewhat
smooth, uh, uh, spatially.
But really in general,
we could have any set of
variables connected with, uh,
a bunch of different factors. In
this case, I'll need showing pair,
uh, factors that are over
pairs of variables. They,
but they could be over a triplets or,
or more.
And then the Lou people leave propagation.
I'm going to could be applied also
on these, uh, types of graphs. Um,
you have to be careful.
It doesn't, like I said,
loopy belief propagation or belief
propagation on new peak graphs is not
necessarily guaranteed to converge
on this. You're a careful,
that's not something I'm going to cover,
but I encourage you to
look at the literature.
If you have you encountered problems
where you actually want these more
complicated structure, uh,
to, uh, model your problem
and final lien.
Uh,
I just want to show the expression
for what to do with these messages.
So intuitively these
messages correspond to a,
what is the sum of all the variable nodes.
Uh,
that's, uh, that's, uh, our
nuts. The current variable, no,
they come from a surgeon,
uh, direction from the graph.
And so if you want it to
compute the marginal probability
of the label somewhere
in the graph, well, uh,
to get its approximate approximated
marginal that approximately at marginal,
we just take a similarly
as we've done before,
the exponential of the luck factor
that involves on the dat a variable.
And then plus the messages that come
from all the factors that involve,
uh, the a node. Why k, uh,
except the factor that's, uh, the,
the factor that owned
the involves white gave.
We have sun and then we just some the
log messages from these other factors,
uh, from other nodes outside
of the Eh, from other, sorry,
other factor nodes that are
connected to this variable notes.
We'd some all of their log messages and
then with just normalize the numerator
by summing over all values
that are possible for my
variable of interest of the
numerators. So the exponential, uh,
exponentiate at some of luck factors
and log messages. So to sum up,
approximate inference would correspond
to something over all the luck factors
that involve only the
variable of interest. Why Gay?
So this is this term here.
In this example I'm showing just
one luck factor, but you can have,
you can have more than one,
then you some over all the log messages
that come into why k from other factors.
So it's this sum here. Then
you take the exponential, uh,
the exponential of those,
some of luck factors and log messages,
and then we normalize to ensure
that we get a valid distribution.
Okay,
so this sums up the general
belief propagation algorithm
for general conditional
random fields.